now you may never want to eat chicken
again after you watch this video
99.9 of all the chicken sold in the
world comes from factory farms where
they can grow a chicken within 42 days
that's less than six weeks I mean a
full-grown chicken chicken is the most
genetically manipulated animal protein
that you can consume you know in the
past long ago a chicken would take a
good amount of time to grow and that's a
normal process but now they've speeded
it up by a factor of 65 times faster so
anytime you alter mother nature and you
grow something that fast there are some
consequences with nutrition I mean if
you take a cow for example you can't
grow a cow in six weeks it takes like
one to two years so I'm going to show
you in a little bit a comparison between
the nutrition in beef versus chicken but
it's so interesting to me that people
are just really against red meat and
they think that white meat is better for
some reason maybe because it's leaner
because of the fat but that's actually
completely false also these poor
chickens are raised in very inhumane
environments
um tens of thousands of chickens in one
room and they're called free range right
but it's very private it's not very
transparent as far as what goes on when
they factory farm chickens there's
something called ammonia burn which from
all the waste that builds up it can
create ulcers on their corneas and it
can affect their joints so overall very
unhealthy environment so I have a
question maybe you heard of eating raw
fish right Sushi or maybe even a rare
steak but why don't people ever eat raw
or wear chicken meat right you pull up
to your fast food restaurant and ask for
a chicken sandwich but you want it on
the rare side it just doesn't happen why
because of the risks of salmonella
caplobacter or E coli these are
pathogenic microbes why would these
pathogens be in chicken but yet you
don't see them in other animal products
well it has to do with the environment
that these chickens are raised in this
is not a normal thing in fact these
microbes even grow within our body and
they don't harm us unless the
environment changes and it becomes more
stressful and they can go from being
neutral to pathogenic so this is why
when you buy a chicken from a grocery
store and you're cutting up a raw
chicken and you're using knives and
you're using a cutting board and then
you put it in the oven right you really
have to sterilize The Cutting Board your
hands the utensils that you use the
knife you use or chances are there's a
high chance you're going to have these
microbes present and then that can
create a big time infection in you but
of course everyone knows that you have
to cook the heck out of chicken to make
sure you kill the pathogens
second question why do they have to
flavor chicken meat and I'm not talking
about going to Kentucky Fried Chicken
you go to a grocery store and you buy
chicken breast in a package they're raw
look in the back of the label why do
they add flavorings in the ingredients
that is because if they don't it's not
going to taste like anything right well
why is that because of the way they're
grown how fast they're grown they're
grown so fast the chicken hasn't have a
chance to develop certain flavor
chemicals the third question
why do they have to add colorings to the
chicken Meats that's right they have to
give the chicken certain pigments to
change the color to make it look like
healthy chicken meat or else it might
look a bit gray right and you wouldn't
eat that but I'm not kidding they
actually color chicken meat to make it
look more appetizing so unfortunately I
have this product that's grown in a very
short period of time very inexpensively
they have to flavor it they have to
color it they have to make it look like
chicken but really is it chicken the
real big problem with chicken on top of
that is that chicken is very high in
omega-6 fatty acids especially compared
to the omega-3 fatty acids which makes
it more inflammatory okay very
inflammatory it's like 14 to 1. we need
it to be one to one okay but it's
fourteen to one it's pretty high and
there's something else you need to know
there's rendered ingredients in this
definition of rendered that means you're
boiling it or you're doing some
something to separate out certain parts
of this product you might be boiling off
the fat or separating certain
particulates out of something so in
commercial chicken feeds okay there's
rendering products and one is called
yellow grease yellow grease now what is
yellow Grace well it's used cooking oil
and it definitely sounds better than
deep fried vegetable waste oil or waste
grease they recycle deep fried seed oils
that have been fried probably for weeks
or months and then they're going to
recycle that back in the feed so not
only is it chicken consuming like things
like soy and corn very high and omega-6
but they also have this additional thing
in the feed unfortunately because you
can kill two birds first of all it's a
hazard in landfills right so that way
why don't we just put it into the feed
for animals which we indirectly eat so
now you know why you can go to Costco
and buy a chicken for four bucks it's
like two dollars a pound I mean that
blows me away now I personally have
about 16 chickens and what I'm talking
about
is completely different than those
chickens which eat bugs all day long and
worms and things like that and I feed
them fermented grains no soy no corn not
GMO it's organic feed but the big point
is I know what it takes to buy the feed
a high quality feed to feed these
chickens and to be able to sell a
full-grown chicken for four dollars with
all the different people involved the
distributor the store the farmer I mean
that is incredible someone could
actually even make a profit on that they
probably don't make a profit but the
point is that to grow a healthy chicken
to grow healthy eggs it does take high
quality ingredients it takes time it
takes money
but unfortunately people demand the
cheapest food possible and of course you
get what you pay for and that's what I'm
going to talk about in the next slide
low nutrition so let's compare
beef versus chicken I'm not even really
comparing grass-fed beef okay except
right here this is just conventional
beef if we compared grass-fed beef which
I will recommend a video at the end it's
a whole different picture but if we
compare look at B12 we got
2.64 versus 0.3 that's like comparing
the rdas 43 versus 5 there's more zinc
okay there's more iron there's more
potassium there's more choline which is
good for your liver there's more folate
and take a look at this the omega-6 to 3
ratio should be one to one
14 to 1 right with beef if you take
grass fed it's two to one if you take
grain it's nine to one so you can see
there's much less omega-6 the
inflammatory oils when you do grass-fed
versus grains because grains are very
high in omega-6 now since we're on the
topic of animal protein and a healthy
protein Source you should really check
out this video on some interesting
research on beef check it out